right now the disease were focused on is
polio World finish smallpox officially
in 1980 was when they signed the
certificate polio we hope to get done
get our certificate by 2018 and then if
you know the credibility the energy from
that will allow us to take the new tools
we'll have then and go after a malaria
plan I also wanted to ask you about the
p6 the cake the keg of life as you
called it well often something will be
invented and people won't realize that
it has a use in poor countries you can
make these thermoses that leak the heat
leaks in very very slowly you know that
was invented like 15 years ago and
nobody thought oh well hey we can help
poor countries with this cold same
problem because for them they don't have
electricity even getting kerosene and
propane is expensive it's unreliable we
built the first one about a year ago and
now they're out in the field you don't
need that in the United States because
our refrigerators are very reliable you
we assume we have 24-hour electricity we
assume patients can easily get to the
doctor so the matching of the good ideas
with the the big important needs that's
a pretty imperfect process you seem very
careful actually not to talk about
giving money away and instead repeatedly
said that you're giving money back
well capitalism is a weird system I mean
it's a fantastic system it provides an
incentive for people to work but it
means that somebody who by having
certain skills and creating a company at
the right time can end up with a
mind-blowing amount of resources so
Melinda and I my wife when talked about
this where's the greatest injustice
where can a dollar
save a life or avoid malnutrition in
setting that that's why we end up saying
boy and poor countries may have this
huge impact I wonder if you can kind of
talk about where you see the health care
system of Ethiopia in five or ten years
and when you see that making a sort of
overall economic impact in the health of
the country well the last ten years
they've gotten their tried to death rate
down from over fifteen percent down to
about eight percent
and they should be able to get it down
below two percent the u.s. is below one
percent also the malnourishment which
you see through stunting still pretty
high here and by finding the children
that aren't growing getting nutritious
foods out improving agricultural
productivity they ought to be able to
virtually eliminate malnutrition that
means Ethiopia will and this is their
stated goal be a middle-income country
by 2025 they absolutely can get there
and you know the progress is is there
exciting health is such an enabling
piece and the country's really pulling
together the system is well-designed
you know the donors like ourselves are
here and trying to think okay what tools
are missing so it's a very positive
story one that I don't think most people
know about
[Music]